in a torrential rainstorm just after
Dawn the picket line took shape as an
insight into how determined and
desperate these workers are the
willingness to stand and protest in
these conditions speaks volumes UK price
inflation is 10.7 percent the government
is offering these work as a pay rise of
just two we are marginally above the
national minimum wage marginally just a
hare's whisker I don't think people
really appreciate just how far low we've
Fallen instead of Staffing these
passport control desks at airport
arrivals one thousand quarter Force
officers have begun an eight-day walkout
over pay pensions and redundancy terms
six airports and one Seaport are
affected
the Border Force strike will affect
nearly 9 000 inbound flights carrying an
estimated 1.7 million passengers
the worst effector will be London
Heathrow with more than 900 000
passengers expected to be delayed during
the strike days but the impact will be
felt nationwide at Manchester Airport
more than a quarter of a million
passengers will be affected
using military personnel to staff the
passport control desks appears to have
minimized the disruption so far on
social media some passengers reported no
cues quicker than usual and passing
through border control in the quickest
time in 10 years
but there's a growing wave of industrial
unrest across several different groups
of public sector workers while the UK
government is refusing to enter
negotiations with the unions
prime minister Rishi sunak has expressed
disappointment at the strikes that
insists pay Rises would only fuel
further inflation it's a difficult
question of setting public sector pay
the government has acted fairly and
reasonably in accepting all the
recommendations of the public sector pay
review bodies that's an independent
process that government has listened to
you know I urge everybody who's
traveling at the moment to just please
check before you make your journey so
you know what's happening public
sentiment public support for the
strikers could be crucial in the days
and weeks ahead at the moment it seems
public support is with the strikers by a
small margin more people blame the
government for the ongoing disputes than
the unions additional public Sector
Strike days have been announced for
January this is turning into a battle of
attrition
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera Heathrow